trevor lawrence eventually will have a
team in the nfl and it likely will be
the jacksonville jaguars here's urban
meyer from the peter king podcast
talking about whether lawrence will
indeed be the first overall pick in the
draft
is there any real mystery that you're
picking trevor lawrence
uh i'd have to say that's the direction
we're going and uh i'll leave that up to
the owner when we make that decision
official
but i i'm certainly not stepping out of
line that that's certainly the direction
we're headed
i i think that
urban has gotten the unofficial memo
to not say anything that would in any
way undermine the ultimate reality show
about nothing you know there was a time
back before the rookie wage scale when
these contracts took five minutes to
negotiate because everything's set in
stone ahead of time where teams would
actually sign the first overall pick
before the draft so what does it do it
completely removes the first pick in the
draft of any
mystery drama tension
so i think the nfl makes it clear to the
owners and the owners make it clear to
their employees we will not in any way
shape or form
make it clear what we're doing with the
first pick in the draft because they
want maximum eyeballs to tune in for the
first 15 minutes on abc espn and nfl
network to see what happens i i think
that's why he said what he said chris i
i meg you you brought that to my
attention like maybe two years ago i
think it was and i i think you're you're
right i think you're spot on i mean it
is it's part of the show it is just and
again even though we know
they're gonna pick trevor lawrence
you know as long as they don't say it we
still go into it thinking well i don't
know if somebody makes them an offer
they can't you know refuse who knows
what they'll do
it just does it adds a little theater
but come on let's be serious we know we
know yeah i i think zach wilson is the
best quarterback in the draft i do but
urban meyer took that job because of
trevor lawrence that's why he took the
job
and of course all the hype and the
attention that comes with trevor
lawrence and people have been spoon-fed
for the last three years that he's the
greatest thing to come out since you
know sliced bread or whatever that is so
there's just too much fanfare he's too
good of a player he's too big in that
part of the country
um that i just that that's who's going
there urban meyer could say whatever he
wants or whatever and you know i know
like i like where he was like he made a
comment like you know i know him but i
don't really know him yeah right you
know we saw you at this pro day you were
all there helping him out doing
everything so uh it's gonna be trevor
lawrence at number one and i don't see
there's any way of that not happening
he he said at a press conference and he
repeated to peter king that he was there
hovering over trevor lawrence so he
could number one put pressure on him and
number two hear the ball come out of his
hands and i think it's important that he
got that kind of a look at lawrence
chris because zach wilson and we're
gonna talk more about his pro day coming
up in a little bit but meyer wasn't
there for the pro day and i saw somebody
suggest that this was some sort of a
smoke screen or something well the smoke
screen would be to be there that would
be the thing that maybe if the jets have
fallen completely in love with zach
wilson maybe there's a way to get the
jets to come up to one and take wilson
you still get lawrence at two you have
to act like you're interested in wilson
to sell that not going to the zack
wilson pro day
underscores the fact that you're all in
on trevor lawrence and there's no reason
to be coy about it there's no one that's
going to jump you and there's no other
way you're going to get trevor lawrence
unless you convince the other teams that
you're interested in someone else no yes
i mean i agree with everything you said
there uh you know we laid out all the
reasons of why you take a trevor
lawrence and then you know there's of
course a lot of football reasons too
trevor lawrence is really good yeah i
think zach wilson is better but trevor
lawrence is worthy of the number one
pick in the nfl draft there's no doubt
about that i got no issue with that
whatsoever and i do think with urban
meyer you know and the offense that he's
gonna run is gonna be very similar to
what we've seen with urban meyer at ohio
state in florida utah wherever and
that's going to be in a quarterback in a
shotgun and a quarterback than trevor
lawrence who's going to be running an
offense that's similar to what he ran in
college yeah it's going to be shotgun
handed off read options you know quick
screen out to the wide receiver and then
some aggressive down the field throws
off of some of those type of things we
just talked about but it is i expect it
to be more of an ecology type offense
trevor lawrence fits that and i i fully
expect it to be that guy i do
you know urban meyer also told peter
king that there's zero chance he's gonna
be another nick saban and hang around
for a couple of years and then be gone i
i don't think you ever want to say zero
chance
of anything you don't know and
a lot can happen between now and the end
of the 2022 season two years in for
urban meyer so yeah you know but we wait
look we we know to take these things
with a grain of salt by now don't we i
will not be the alabama coach i mean if
he's happy he'll stay if he's not why
stay he's on the wrong side of 55 as am
i and uh why are you going to do
anything at that age that you aren't
happy doing you should never do anything
life's too short to do things you're not
happy doing but as you get closer and
closer to the end of the road why do
things you don't want to do chris it
makes no sense no no it it does not i i
expect you know him really i look at it
to think that this would probably be
urban meyer's last job you know i don't
worry about urban going somewhere else
or being one of those type of things
like nick saban from miami to alabama i
worry more about like what we've talked
about with urban meyer in the past when
they first talked about hiring him it's
just that after two three years
he we've seen he he can get burnt out
you know i understand it's a stressful
job he seems like he's a psycho in a
good way right and i mean that in the
fact that yeah he can't leave his job at
the job he takes it home he thinks about
it he stresses him out you know it it
probably goes into his personal life all
of those things that's what you worry
about with urban meyer i'm interested to
see how he you know just
he acts and feels in the nfl altogether
because in the nfl
i will say you know there is less bs for
lack of a better way to say it you know
you're not having to recruit and write
letters and call this guy and oh let me
talk to little johnny's mommy and daddy
because his mommy and daddy aren't happy
that he didn't play last week and all
that kind of crap you know he might find
it refreshing it might just be like man
this is just football and the only thing
i got to do every now and then is just
tell a guy like why were you late for
meetings today or this or that there's
less babysitting to go on and i think
i'm interested to see maybe if he kind
of finds it refreshing or does he kind
of find it like oh this isn't for me i'm
a college guy all together it'll be
interesting to see how it all goes
you can't stack the deck with 10 first
round picks every year
that's the problem that is the other
side of it though is your season is done
with one or two losses if you're at ohio
state because your objective is to win
the national championship and one or two
losses it's gone it's over you can go
seven and five through 12 games and
still win the super bowl you can hover
around 500 if you are able when the
season is on the line to find the gas
pedal now you still have to have good
players and again you can't stack the
deck with great players and i think
that's what frustrated nick saban among
other things i just think he is suited
to being in a college town i think his
wife prefers to be in a college town the
pro game was not for him he tried it it
didn't work and he's never had any
inclination to come back and try to
rectify it he knows what he wants to do
and he's doing what he wants to do and
that's going to be the question for
urban meyer is this what you want to do
once you've had a full year
or two
of it and if it isn't
why keep going just to prove that you
were right when you said there's zero
chance how can he say with certainty
there's zero chance when he has no idea
what it's going to feel like you can
talk to everyone who's ever coached at
the nfl level and you still don't know
how it's going to feel for you when you
do it no i'm with you mike and i'm
certainly not believing any coach when
it comes to any of that stuff come on
we've already brought this up shanahan
lynch we're gonna keep this quarterback
we're gonna do this in the draft we
don't know don't listen to any of them
with any of this stuff you know and and
to urban myers defense too you know in
his own mind he probably does think it's
zero right now it's like a great athlete
they convince themselves like this is it
this is all i'm gonna do i'll never do
that again oh until
oh the notre dame gets job gets offered
to me five years from now oh then maybe
i'll get into that you know i mean we
don't know i'm just throwing that out
there i'm not trying to say no but no no
but you're right because really what
what and what else can he say right
there are
many must lie situations for football
coaches peter king asks him are you
going to be like nick saban is he going
to say well i don't know i have to see
then then that that bumps the 49ers
trade off of our top segment of the show
urban meyer isn't sure he sold on the
nfl and then we've talked about that for
30 minutes so he said what he had to say
to keep it from being a story deep down
though you reserve the right to change
your mind and we've seen him change his
mind many times and especially guys who
have made their career at the college
level where there is so much easy
mobility one of the things he said is he
was trying to put his staff together he
didn't realize these nfl contracts are
like real like you just can't walk away
whenever you feel like it and go coach
somewhere else right no at the college
level it's easier to do at the nfl it's
a different ball game but no one is
going to force you to stay if you don't
want to stay and i think that's what it
comes down to to urban you know the one
thing that's been guarded pretty closely
is what the jaguars are paying him i was
told he wanted 12 million a year and
there was some weird rebuttal to that
like he doesn't okay he wants less than
that i mean what why someone fighting
back against the notion that he wanted
12 million a year they've managed to
keep under wraps what he's actually
getting i i think that is going to be a
factor at some point right i mean you
have to weigh
the headache the pain in the butt the
stress against the compensation and the
more you make the more crap you're
willing to put up with so i think that's
part of it as well where's that that
that dividing line between
they're paying me enough that i'll deal
with something that really isn't great
right versus they're not paying me
enough and i'm too old for this oh yeah
you're you're right you know it's it's a
different intensity when the nfl
compared to the college like we talked
about college where you got to worry
about kids and their parents and the
recruiting and all of that you know nfl
yeah you don't have to do as much as
that type of stuff i mean we know that
and you're going to get a few breaks
here and there but
you know the intensity of the work
goes up another level
and
like you said you can't go into the game
going well i got 10 first round picks
and this team we're playing's got none
of them we're okay we don't have to do
anything crazy x's and o's wise if we
just play football and tackle and do the
right things we'll win the football game
now
it becomes wait no no my x's and o's
need to be the difference in the
football game to help our team win i
don't have the talent advantage so it's
the grind of that and then the season
getting over and the grind of getting
into film right away and free agency and
everybody's looking at the same players
and where am i gonna find the advantage
of you know i think this guy for a
little less money can fit my team and
all of that in the draft that's where it
just it's a different intensity and it's
more pressure i think on
the coach
you know from that standpoint as far as
fury pure football expectations
and less personal i can communicate to
people and recruit expectations and
that's where i'll be interested to see
how urban meyer really handles all that
and you've got to adapt quickly to a new
world we've seen him complain about free
agency in the nfl how you have to
evaluate and agree to terms with guys
you don't get a chance to fully vet he's
talked about all sorts of differences
between the pro game and the college
game all he knows is the college game so
here he is 56 57 and he's jumping into
something that is football but it's very
different from the football that he's
used to we'll see how it goes for him
but yep uh it could go very well like
jimmy johnson it could go very poorly
like nick saban or it could end up
somewhere in between we'll find out
coming up this fall
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports